c'est le troisième plus gros tournoi de
tennis en ile-de-france la 27ème édition
de l'open de plaisir se déroule jusqu'au
24 septembre au tennis club de la
commune
cette année plus de 600 joueurs venus de
toute l'europe s'affrontent sur l'école
les marchands très disputée les joueurs
ça vont gagner quelques points atp qui
vont leur permettre de défaire des trois
challengers demain et peut être demain
des grands chelems
donc tout ça c'est une évidence et c'est
pour cette raison que ce tournoi me
plaît bien
c'est le sport de haut niveau qui a son
visage naturel si je puis dire avec sa
dotation à 25000 dollars le rendez-vous
est intégré au futur la 6è catégorie des
tournois de tennis
déjà on a des arbitres à la déchetterie
après c'est un futur en ait des
changements de balle on a des serviettes
des bouteilles d'eau ça a fait on est un
peu comme sur un mini mini roland
università aussi c'est vrai ce ne sera
pas et on est considérés comme des très
bons joueurs donc ça fait toujours
plaisir
sur le plan sportif le tournoi est
réputé pour faire éclore des talents
l'événement a révélé de nombreux
professionnels tricolore c'est quoi les
futurs champions de demain
les deux sont galets mahut et cetera les
llodra et compagnie sont passés par là
donc nous avons les futurs champions de
demain
la future pépite du tennis français se
trouve peut-être sur les courts cette
année si vous voulez les voir à l'oeuvre
et finales sont programmées ce dimanche
24 septembre à partir de 13h30 sur les
courts plaisir oit